let's talk first maybe um i know that
you've got a whole list of companies
that you think are kind of like rocket
ship companies that could have really
high upside for people to go join maybe
walk us through first when you think
about these types of companies what is
the framework you use to evaluate
whether it's something that would go on
the list or not go on the list all right
so listen so my wife about five years
ago when she wanted a job we thought
what can where can she work that has a
very high salary high perks
not cushy but like not like a a 30
person or 10 person startup or you're
grinding your butt off and you have zero
resources we thought what company could
she work at then that is very
competitive and also has the possibility
to maybe 10x inequity
and so we made a list and then we went
and i helped her apply and
and she ended up getting a job at airbnb
and i don't remember what their
valuation was five years ago but i think
it was like
20 billion now it's
uh
uh what's it 90 90 billion yeah it's
much higher
and so if you do the map let's say that
you're given 250 000 in stock or 400 000
in stock something like that and you
divide that up by four years you can
make millions of dollars that way
and so this is like the strategy that
we've kind of like or i've helped her
kind of live by and so i made a list of
companies that i think you can work at
now that are pretty safe you're not
going to grind you're going to get great
help health benefits great
other types of perks and benefits you
can get make a lot of money in salary
you know like a facebook style google
style salary and also if you own some of
their stock that could potentially make
you millions and so we call it sarah's
list
and so i've got i've got i've got a few
of them all right what's the first one
and i bet you've got a few of them too
by the way um all right the first one
all right we'll start with something
easy the first one zapier you know
zapier yep do you like automation type
stuff yeah i'm i'm so bullish on zapier
so zapier is a uh 350-person company uh
they're completely remote they've been
remote they raised only 1.3 million
dollars and with that 1.3 million
dollars they got close to 80 million in
arr which is pretty phenomenal
uh the founder his name is wade foster
i've met him he's amazing what they do
is basically the simplest way
the way that you describe them is kind
of complicated but they connect api so a
very simple format is you uh i had a
scale that was a smart scale i stepped
on it i weighed myself that smart scale
was connected through zapier zapier then
put it in a google sheet where i could
track my weight and then also it emailed
out all my friends what my weight was so
it shamed me into being skinny so that's
like the simplified version now imagine
that on uh your business using that on
steroids so like pop every time you get
an email about that use the word um
uses some certain word it categorizes
that email into google sheets in a
certain way and you can but you can do
that with thousands of different uh
software so it's pretty amazing and when
you think about a company like that if
you were to say okay hey this might be
one that i want to go work out how do
you think about cash versus equity
compensation is it something where you
want all cash or is it something where
you want all equity or some balance
i so i would want it i would want a
competitive salary and i would want a
lot of equity
[Laughter]
and i think you could push for both a
lot of these companies i mean look i
think you can get i think a lot of these
companies you can get like for a 28 29
you know so you're
five years out of out of school five
years six year experience i think this
is a place where you can make
200 250 000 a year and also get 150 200
000 a year in stock so that's a total
comp package of 500 000 i think that's
very possible and then my bet personally
is what i'd be trying to do is if i'm
getting 200 thousand dollars of stock i
stay there for four years that's at 800
000. i'd want my 800 000 to turn into
two three four million
got it what's the next one
all right next one all right this one's
uh a little controversial because the
founder's a little different all right
have you heard of uh andrew
andero yeah palmer lucky and uh what
trey steve yeah i think right
yeah so palmer lucky he started oculus
when he was like 18 or something sold it
when he was 21 of facebook for over a
billion dollars he's controversial
not really that big of a deal but he's a
big trump supporter and he claims he got
fired from facebook for being a trump
supporter so most of silicon valley is
left to center so for that reason it's a
little controversial which in my opinion
actually makes it better because there's
probably less applicants so your chances
of getting to work there are actually
higher and so what they do is basically
when the have you ever seen the movie
war dogs yes
great
it's awesome right so when the
government needs something they put out
a bid and people bid and then they make
whatever it is they get the bid and then
they make it make whatever it is that
they put the bid on andrew uses data and
a bunch of other stuff to kind of guess
what they think the government will need
and they just go ahead and build it and
the government hopefully buys it from
them that's kind of their business model
the first thing they did was they made
they use drones to create a wall between
the mexico and america border
and they're doing a bunch of other weird
stuff like that so they have like towers
that they can make that can help track
people so kind of like not for everyone
but they raised money at a 4.6 billion
valuation i think this company could
easily be worth 50 billion or more oh i
completely agree this to me is one of
those companies where there's definitely
a bunch of people in the tech industry
who uh they don't like the defense
department they don't like the
government they uh feel like they
shouldn't um you know work with it they
don't want to take government contracts
whatever uh but then the government
needs help right and i actually think
that having technologists and people who
are competent and experienced uh
building this technology is probably
better than uh letting the legacy
defense contractors do it um and so this
company 50 billion i think is uh you
know i want to say a layup but uh but
probably conservative if this that's my
point yeah if this company ends up being
successful it'll probably be worth
hundreds of billions of dollars over
time just because they'll start it's
kind of like spacex right they literally
start to almost get a stranglehold on
government contracting in a specific
sector whereas now like who competes
with spacex for uh some of these uh
contracts it's really not that many
people like that a lot yeah maybe like a
blue origin pops up every now and then
or maybe a virgin or something uh
there's a couple of other companies who
kind of sort of uh try to compete but
it's the beauty of government
contracting is if you do something
really really well and it's a big market
then you're the only one who does it
like they got to work with you
yeah so i'm bullish on this company and
they've raised money at 4.6 billion
dollars that sounds like a lot that's a
[ __ ] steal that's a steal this is
gonna be worth way more than that i
think that if you got a million dollars
of equity broken down over four years at
this company so 250 a year or 200 a year
i think that definitely can be worth 10
times that could be worth up to 10
million
yeah i think this is a great company to
work at but it's not for everyone
i uh i like this one way better than the
zapier one only because i think that
this has like such significant upside so
i completely agree with you on this one
all right what's the next one
all right
so
do you know what adobe is of course you
do yeah so adobe do you realize that
adobe is like the 30th largest company
in the world no
and that's crazy right 315 billion
dollar market cap massive massive
company well you probably know what
these guys are have you heard of figma
everyone is here yeah like the design
software okay so this one's a little bit
weird but all right so figma is
basically photoshop online it's
basically photoshop plus google docs uh
they've raised a lot of money 10 billion
dollars um and so it's very simple to
explain it's just photoshop online and
collaborative so you can like see
people's cursor moving they raise money
at a 10 billion valuation but adobe
freaking huge it's so big they make so
much money from photoshop and from the
creative suite i think figma absolutely
can 10x i know that sounds crazy is that
a 10 billion company can be 100 billion
company that's a little nuts but adobe
is so so big the market for this is so
large i i'm pretty bullish on figma how
much of what figma is doing is just hey
we have the same functionality in like a
slicker interface versus there's like
true technology improvement
i i like i don't know
i'm like i'm like a neanderthal so when
i use it like i could do some drag and
drop i mean i use powerpoint for uh
photoshop stuff so but i do think that
it's quite good um i i would say in my
opinion it seems like it's a similar
thing as photoshop but online
got it okay next one
all right let's do another one um all
right this one's kind of a boring one
but still pretty safe i think this one
could be worth 10x what it is now have
you heard of rippling rippling yeah this
is um what is it parker conrad and he's
doing like the small business uh
software
yeah so this guy named parker conrad he
started this company's benefits at the
time when benefits came out it was the
fastest growing startup ever i believe
uh
the fastest growing by revenue and he
got in trouble because basically two
things were happening he created this
bro culture and people are like having
sex in the stairwells and like they got
a lot of flack for that and the second
thing he did is if you want to sell so
basically his company was called zenfits
and it was an hr uh software and it
allowed people to get
benefits so if you're a small business
if your pumps show and you have
five or ten employees you put them on
this platform and it helps them pick
their benefits and they can sort through
which benefits and they categorize it
whatever well this guy in order to sell
that and sell insurance you need your
employees to become licensed insurance
brokers and he basically created a
program like a macro where they could
just like click a bunch of buttons on
the screen and it auto approved them as
a
as a broker because they like watched
some presentations so we got fired for
that
i love that i love when people get fired
for doing dumb stuff and they make up
for it and so his new company is called
rippling and so basically it's very
boring
but here's the thing
everyone freaking needs this everyone
every small business needs exactly what
rippling's selling it does a few things
that are amazing basically if you want
health insurance you sign up and your
employees can pick their health
insurance they do your payroll and they
do like a little bit other
small things like for example when you
have a company with 30 people and
everyone has a different laptop it
attracts who has a laptop and you can
turn it off once they quit or once you
fire them just a little simple [ __ ]
valued at 1.3 billion dollars
uh do you know what work day is work
days like the big dog in the space was
it 25
uh what are they valued at yeah uh let
me see i think higher uh probably 50.
let's see
workday 66 billion wow and there's
yeah and then there's paychecks they're
a big payroll provider i think they're
at 50. so rippling at 1.3 it's way
better than workday and i've used a lot
of these things it's way better i think
that this is a steal super boring so
this would be perfect for a sales person
hey guys bang bang thanks so much for
watching the best business show today
and don't forget to check out our
partner sofi they make all this possible
they're a super app that lets you save
spend borrow earn and invest all from
one single platform and if you go there
today and you sign up for a sofi invest
account you can get between five dollars
and a thousand bucks for free from sofa
not everyone's obviously gonna get a
thousand dollars but everyone gets
something don't say that i never did
anything for you go check them out at
sofi.com
download the app and go ahead and open
an account sofi.com pomp and make sure
you come back and watch more of the best
business show we're going to build the
biggest business show in the world and
we need your help
[Music]